[Music]
hey y'all
what's going on yeah had to be
unenthusiastic against whether to get
made
up now well because now i have a complex
no
just so it's like no yeah because
everything i do it's
everything i do it's weird or wrong or
whatever
listen listen to her auntie what that's
not true yes yes it is
it's in your mind yeah it's in your mind
yeah yeah
i know how you do it i'm just teasing
stop it
yeah all right so today we're talking
but this should be like
kind of interesting because we're not
exactly doing a movie we're doing a
netflix series hi pokey yeah
what we were doing because remember
somebody said that we needed to watch
uh there was a series on netflix about
the pinkertons yeah
and so we went to netflix last night to
look for it i found out subsequently
that it's actually not on netflix
anymore
okay so i don't so i don't know if we
can find it someplace else
but while we went to netflix we noticed
that they had dropped the second season
of the movies that made us yeah so we
saw the second season so we watched this
it's only four episodes it was they're
about 45 48 minutes long
a piece so we just sat there and watched
all four of them even though i was super
tired but i managed to like stay awake
for all of them
yeah it was uh back to the future that
was the first one
pretty woman uh jurassic park park and
forest gotten thor's going for the four
that were covered
yeah really to me the only interesting
ones of course were back to the future
and
and jurassic park the other ones i
thought were kind of boring but yeah
it's still a good series
i mean i like i i'm not a big fan of
forrest gump like the movie
and i liked pretty woman but i haven't
seen it in so long that it's like i
barely remembered anything about it
but i'm kind of still interested in
because i'm just interested in like
people that write the scripts i'm
interested in people that do special
effects i'm interested in like all the
kind of stories behind
the movies so even if it's a movie i'm
not really that into
i still find it interesting because i
like seeing like all the people
pretty women was [ __ ]
you got this [ __ ] billionaire [ __ ]
business mogul hooks up with a [ __ ]
hollywood street hooker and ends up
marrying her i think
eventually didn't he yeah wait did he
marry her see i've spent so long since
i think he did eventually he was in love
with her total [ __ ]
total [ __ ] would never happen well
it was a rom-com yeah um
but the interesting thing about that and
here was something that i didn't know
was that pretty woman was not only one
of the first kind of like
i don't say like adult movie not adult
like a porn movie but like
more adult oriented what are you doing
poke she was trying to pull [ __ ] off the
chair hey you leave it alone okay stop
it poking
she's like no one's paying attention to
me i have to destroy
pull off the chair yeah she has to
destroy something it's like no one's
paying it you're so cute pokey we you
know i love you we know we love you
but um but yeah so it was the so disney
had wanted to go off into like
touchstone so this was when they started
uh
you know they're doing their offshoot
touchstone because they were kind of
just known for doing like animated
movies right for kids movies
so they wanted another thing where they
could do like uh you know movies for
adults obviously
so this was one of the first ones that
they put into production
so they were talking to the guy that
wrote the original screenplay which was
called 3000
um you know was the first thing i
thought it was like 300 like the
gladiators i'm like okay that's weird
but i guess it was because three
thousand dollars was like how much he
paid her like to spend the week just and
i had forgotten about that too
but when he wrote the screenplay it was
supposed to be like a gritty
serious i mean the bones of the story
were the same
like billionaire corporate raider dude
like
like uh hires a prostitute for a week
and then you know
shenanigans it too but it was but it was
much darker
and so i think like the more they went
into it like the funnier it got
and it was just kind of like the thing
that amazes me i think about this show
is that and particularly the one about
back to the future right because that
was like the first one and that was like
the best one because that's the movie
that i like the best out of all the ones
that they did
and it's funny to think now because back
to the future
is kind of like one of the most perfect
movies ever made
right of any kind or any era actually
the trilogy too
yeah but i mean well i'm being just in
the context of the show where they were
talking about the first movie
i was kind of like and so it's kind of
interesting to
think how long that it took to get it
made
how many iterations it went through how
many problems they had
how many times it wasn't gonna get made
how many times like you know what i mean
and it's like all of the [ __ ] stupid
like studio interference no we need to
call it space man from pluto
um you know the whole thing which i
think most people that know about back
to the future know that uh michael j
fox who was actually their first choice
for the movie couldn't do it because he
was doing family ties
so they got eric stultz instead and then
they had shot like what six weeks of the
movie
yeah and then they were like okay well
eric stoltz isn't working out
he was taking it too seriously yeah it's
like i don't think that he got
well well yeah he kind of saw it more
which if you think about it
he kind of saw it more as like a sad
existential type of which like i said
you could kind of look at it that way if
you wanted to
but they were trying to do like a more
lighthearted comedy thing and eric
stultz was kind of playing it serious
and it wasn't really like tonally it
wasn't really working out
so then finally they got michael j fox
to do it and so
like you know they've and i was like the
whole scene where i was like stressed
out it's like it happened a long time
ago but they were just kind of like and
then we had to tell eric stultz that he
was like essentially fired after six
weeks of work
but they said that he was actually kind
of relieved because i guess he wasn't
having that great a time either
so yeah so there was that whole thing
and that's the thing like eric stoltz is
like a really good actor
but he's usually in more serious kind of
stuff
you know i mean the reason they got him
second well one of the executives like
wanted him because he'd been in that
movie
mask with cher where he was you know he
had that like he was disabled and
everything rocky dennis it's like based
on a real person
and he was really good in that and he
was like in um [ __ ] man what was that
other
it was like pretty in pink but gender
swapped some kind of wonderful
he was in that like the john hughes
movie and he was really good in that
which was
kind of a comedy but more of like a
romantic type of thing like john hughes
did
so so he was good in that so i could see
how it wasn't really working out
i also laughed at all the stuff they
were saying about
chris about uh crispin glover she's
chewing on [ __ ]
she's doing this [ __ ] to get a page yeah
she always she always cheats now she's
running
if she starts chewing like just take
this take this bottle of febreze
and
because i don't i've never sprayed her
with it i would never do that she knows
it hisses though but sometimes when she
if she's chewing on
she starts chewing on like a power cord
or something like that and i have to
keep her from doing it so i'll spray it
like over there like
like that and she's just like no no and
she doesn't like that noise she's
chewing on the drinking straw the the
drinking cable of the [ __ ] hydration
system
out of the rucksack oh okay and look
that was expensive
she's the chewing issue kidding yeah
well then it's like and i have like a
big bag full of like chew sticks that i
give her and she chews on them because
they're like chicken flavored but it's
like
she'll chew on that she'll be like well
i'm just going to chew on all the things
because apparently i can chew on that
and all these other things but yeah so
the okay so the thing that amazed me
like i said was that back to the future
was another one
that because i feel like uh robert
zemeckis and like the other dude they
called him the bobs
like on the show right and they had
written it
or he had the idea like when he was
still back in film school or like when
he was just out of film school or some
[ __ ] like that
and i think the original did the
original ending of back to the future
wasn't it like um how doc brown
who was called professor brown in the
original uh original version
was gonna get the power to send marty
back to the future
was from a nuclear test an a-bomb test
an
a-bomb test yeah back in the 50s yeah
and so
um i guess they were kind of gonna do
that but then like people thought it was
too dark and then like they
because doc brown died in it didn't he i
don't remember if he died another one i
think he died in the explosion
yeah maybe yeah because this was another
one that had like a much darker ending i
guess
because it's like you know everybody got
kind of blown up like didn't everybody
get kind of blown up at the end i think
well i just they just saw this
back but they saw the storyboards i saw
the storyboard they showed the
storyboard and i think it showed [ __ ]
doc brown's [ __ ] face melting
like out of uh out of uh indiana jones
when they opened when they opened the
[ __ ] the ark of the cabinet
yeah yeah that would have been quite a
different movie um but yeah so
there was that and there was also i
think when he went back to the future
that he said
it was supposed to look like super
futuristic like the movie metropolis
like
you know what i mean like yeah like he
had lived or anything it was it was
going to be it was going to be very
different
but what they ended up with is probably
one of the most american movies of all
times
and i think that they just ended up with
with the lightning strike at the end
they kind of just did that because it
was cheaper
because the budget got cut yeah because
they already had a set where they could
do that
yeah what makes sense though yeah and
it's like way less
uh soul-crushing than a right but an
a-bomb that killed yeah
yeah and that wouldn't well it was it
was on a test range yeah
it wasn't an a-bomb [ __ ] you know
launched into a
neighborhood or anything just that
evidently they were going to sneak out
on the test range somehow and
get the power of that a-bomb and channel
it into the damn flux capacitor
yeah but by looking at the storyboards
doc brown didn't survive
that's true all right so and louie said
didn't the terrorists kill doc brown
well they did but then yeah he went back
but then he went back and got warned
about it he was wearing a bulletproof
vest that stopped it yeah
stopped the ak rounds kind of intended
to be dead yeah kanavatsan said eric
stoltz did the fly too it was not a bad
movie yeah i agree like the fly too was
actually uh better than it had any right
to be
um another thing too was that the
original time machine in the original
back to the future
script was supposed to be made out of a
refrigerator
i don't know how that was gonna work
yeah well that ended up being an indiana
jones four
or five yeah what was that four crystal
skull crystal skull that's the fourth
one i think
i think that wasn't a time machine but
he just hit it no
yeah but i think that was that was that
was supposed to be an homage to that i
think to the original
back to the future it might have been
because steven spielberg and all those
guys
were in on that movie one of the reasons
why that movie feels like a spielberg
movie because he was [ __ ] involved in
it
so it does feel like a spielberg movie
he was one of the guys working on it it
was
i think he did a lot he came up with a
lot of the ideas that ended up in the
movie too
they were all friends hanging out
talking about it yeah i mean steven
spielberg
honestly because robert zemeckis he came
out
of um film school and i think like him
and the other bob
they wrote that movie in 1941 that
steven spielberg made but that was like
a big flop right
so so stephen's movie though it was
actually i remember it being pretty good
um
john belushi fighting that p47 tomahawk
yeah that's right
in a good movie it doesn't mean anything
if it was a flop
sometimes movies that are flops deserve
to be but sometimes
they totally so so steven spielberg was
like friends with
bob zemeckis like right when bob
zemeckis was out of uh
film school and the interesting thing
was robert zemeckis like he made
a bunch of movies that were pretty much
all flops like he made like a string of
like three or four of them
yeah crustal was in one of them called
uh used cars used cars yeah
yeah and then so i told you no so the
fact that they were willing to give him
another chance though
i mean the reason that they that they
gave him back to the future was because
he had done
romancing the stone which they only gave
him because they didn't think that movie
was going to do very well so they're
like hey give it to that guy that makes
all the flops
and he made it and it was like this
massive success and honestly i
like it i really liked romancing this
one don't see that one again i saw it
like a zillion times
when i was a kid they played it over and
over again on cable it was on cable
i remember liking it yeah it was kind of
like indiana jones but
you know yeah like an adventure yeah but
in the 80s but like a romantic comedy
also
yeah kind of but like wacky but also
adventure i have to see it again
um yeah and i just it was on
god it was on hulu or amazon prime
because i remember scrolling through and
i'd be like oh man i want to watch that
again because i haven't seen it in such
a long time
out of the movies that they did on the
series though i would just say
back to the future was the most
interesting one
to a certain extent jurassic park some
people don't like that movie i i
remember liking it
in the context of the time it's been a
long time since i've seen
jurassic park when it came out i was
amazed i saw it in the theater well
everyone's was
amazing everyone was amazed by it yeah
it was kind of
a not a complicated movie it was real
kind of shallow you know it wasn't what
you know i mean it didn't really it
wasn't something that really
stuck with you it was just like a
monster just a monster but that's okay
yeah but i remember having a good time
in the theater with it
and it was kind of like watching jumanji
or some [ __ ] like that
like some of the jumanji ones that's uh
that was pretty cool that jumanji too
i've only seen
the second one we had a good time yeah
they're just fun just fun movies just
fun popcorn movies like yeah there's
nothing wrong with that
no and it's just kind of like the thing
that they kind of went into a lot of on
jurassic park
was um you know the special effects
obviously because
you know i think most people know but
it's like what they were gonna do yes
they built these big massive puppets and
stuff like that
you know for close-up shots and whatnot
and they even built that t-rex like
life-size
uh if it wasn't gonna be like moving
around and [ __ ] so that is actually
there it's a big puppet
like an animatronic um but they were
going to do because
this you know it was the 90s early 90s
so they didn't really have really good
cgi
so they were originally going to do all
the dinosaurs are going to be stop
motion and like phil tippett was going
to do it
and so he did a bunch of stuff and then
steven spielberg was like oh it's pretty
good but they had like add motion blur
to it like in
uh post-production so to make it look
more realistic and even then like steven
spielberg was like i don't know it still
looks like a little bit
jerky although they showed some of the
some of the special effects reels from
you know from the spot stop motion it
actually looked pretty good i thought
um but you know but then they had uh
these two guys that were from uh
industrial light and magic
and they were basically on the slide
they were just kind of like we're gonna
figure out how to do like realistic
dinosaurs
in cgi which had never been done before
um they had done other things in cgi but
not like
a something that was supposed to look
like a real animal
so it took them a really really long
time to do it but they finally did it
and they kind of like
they kind of had to go about it in an
underhanded sort of fashion where it's
like they had all the producers and
stuff and then like they kind of snuck
their little they're a little uh real in
there for them to see it and they were
just kind of like oh okay well that's
what we're doing because that looks
amazing
so it was just kind of funny like the
the dude that did
the um that figured out how to do the
cgi dinosaurs he seemed like kind of
uh what's the word that i want to use
don't don't no i'm just
it doesn't it didn't hiss i pulled the
trigger on it because it's dead
oh there it goes yeah oh god okay now
you're getting it all in my
you've got all my drinks i thought it
was i thought it was dead no it's not
empty okay
it's just kind of like i just even the
empty ones i keep them in here because
it's like
all i have to do is take it out and
she's like oh [ __ ] i'm in trouble
because she's not sure that [ __ ] she
doesn't like anything that makes like
she does
every time i do my hair spray like she's
just like she doesn't like that
yeah they they hiss yeah well imagine if
somebody pulled something out they
screamed
[Laughter]
don't scream at me yeah i guess it's
like one of those stupid like air horns
you're like
she threatened to bite it well she knows
that that's how she gets attention
she's like if i do something bad then
daddy will yell at me and he'll come
over here and like play with me
yeah that's what it is because you do
because you do it so she knows it works
yeah everything manipulates me
oh my god but the uh i would say uh
yeah seeing the back to the future one
was the best one somebody sent me
the entire trilogy i still got a sealed
i want to i want to uh
watch that again seeing that thing made
me want to watch all three of them
oh yeah definitely we got to do a show
on all three of them
just in one because really
it's very rare that a trilogy is perfect
that one is actually a perfect trilogy
each movie is is
perfect they're all good and it's it's
and each movie is its own thing
but they're all thematically linked
which i think is really cool it's like
watching this continuation of the same
world
and um now some people would say well
that third one wasn't that no it is that
third one is [ __ ] great
is it the thing is is that the third one
really you don't really appreciate it
until you start getting older
when you're in your 40s or so and above
the third one is a lot better because
it's more of a story about doc brown
yeah and about how dark bro it's a
completion of doc brown's
story arc you know and um
doc's older so you know that so it's
the story itself is not going to appeal
that much
to to young guys it didn't really appeal
to me that much when it first came out
but now that i've now that i've gotten
older i i appreciate it a lot more
um they were all great movies
and like i said it's very rare that a
trilogy holds up i mean even star wars
which is right underneath there and
return to the jedi had a few problems in
there
you know [ __ ] the ewok theme songs
and [ __ ] the goofy [ __ ]
some of that [ __ ] got real [ __ ] goofy
you know
[Laughter]
the best star wars movie i mean
everybody's going to tell you best star
wars empire strikes back i mean well
everybody knows
yeah i don't think anyone's going to
write george lucas really didn't have a
whole lot to do with that
you know it was directed by some other
guy that was directed by the guy that
did
bug and uh robocop
ii yeah which robocop 2 is a cool movie
too a lot of people
don't appreciate that one as much as
they should
roll the top one is a [ __ ]
masterpiece that [ __ ] was insane i'm
getting off topic though yeah well
[Laughter]
i wanted to say though that even though
i'm not a big fan of forrest gump the
movie like i think i kind of liked it
the first time i saw it but then like
subsequent times i'm like man this is
actual it's an actual garbage fire but
um
well it's just like it's like boom it's
like boomer porn and i'm just kind of
like
i'm not about it like as i get older i
didn't really like it as much
but i had forgotten and i just thought
it's funny because i just watched if you
guys um
i really like this channel uh dominic
noble
and he does a series uh called lost an
adaptation
and he talks about like all the
differences like they're really these
in-depth videos like the differences
between like the book and the movie
and he did one very recently on
um and it might be just for patrons only
because i'm i'm on his patreon
but um he did one on forrest gump like
the movie
the or the book by winston groom and i
think i
read that book like a long time ago
because or read part of it because i
remember like one of my family members
or something like had it laying around
and so i was kind of reading it and i
had forgotten how [ __ ]
batshit insane that [ __ ] book is i
mean the movie
is sort of the same but the movie is
like a lot
different they made a lot of changes um
i mean
in the [ __ ] book like he had an
orangutan at one point like he goes to
the [ __ ] moon
it's like there's just and he's like a
big
fat guy and also the um
the thing about the forrest gump in the
book is
that he's kind of a dick and he's kind
of like
because you know in the movie he's kind
of like this sweet good-natured you know
mentally challenged man
whereas in the book it seemed like he
was he says he's an idiot but he seems
to be like smarter than like he's making
people think he's dumb that was the
impression that i got
um so he's kind of like and he's kind of
an [ __ ]
in the book so they made him like a lot
nicer
in the movie and they took a lot of the
weirder [ __ ] out
because i think they did think about
putting the orangutan in there and then
everybody was like no
he goes to the moon that's what i just i
just said that like a couple minutes ago
like just crazy crazy [ __ ] like happens
in the book like yes some of the stuff
that happened in the movie happened in
the book too
but there was so much more and like
listening to
like when i was listening to dominic
noble talking about the book
i was just like oh my god i forgot how
[ __ ] insane
this book is now even in the even on the
show
like one of the producers or you know
the executives or something
was just saying for some reason they're
like they had the book
and i think even before it was published
like they were you know
people were optioning like screenplays
and they had winston groom the guy that
wrote the book
they had him write a screenplay but they
didn't love it because it was like too
close to books they had like other
people do it which is pretty standard
procedure
and uh so they said it sat in a box and
then somebody picked it up and really
dug it
but it seemed like i don't know like
this executive was just like you know
it's really not a very good book
you know what i mean but i guess there
was just something about it that was
like really compelling for people it
wasn't a good movie either
i mean it's kind of entertaining to
watch at the theater i saw it in the
theater when it came out i
might have i can't remember if i was on
the thing it was entertaining
but then it ended and i was like what
the [ __ ] did i just see
what did that mean you know and it
didn't have a meaning it was
it was just mundane people get
everything i mean
didn't it had a [ __ ] there was no or
just it was kind of it was almost kind
of like
you know talking about the movie more
than the book but the movie was kind of
more like
it was almost kind of like a holy fool
narrative where he was just
here's this guy who is tweet natured he
doesn't know any better and he just
somehow
wanders into all these like amazing epic
adventures
i don't think it has any deeper meaning
than that no it was just
it was kind of ironic you had all these
boomers that were just loving it
and they were kind of holding it up as
some
kind of a moralistic tale but to me the
only
morals i can make out of it is that you
can be a loser and still win
because he was a loser yeah you know it
wasn't anything
yeah great and i think a lot of people
imagine themselves as
losers who are winning and it's kind of
like it was feeding into that
feeling some people might have you know
what i mean like
no matter what i do i'm a winner yeah
it's not true
yeah that is not true oracle said yeah
dominic noble's reviews are awesome yeah
i love him
uh yeah grantham's hammer says forrest
gump the novel which the movie is based
on forrest was a racist simpleton yeah
he
basically n word this and word that uh
you know pretty much through the whole
book
so that's another thing you know so so
they like softened him quite a bit
uh from the thing but that was kind of
funny too because
as beloved as that movie is not by me
but by
like a large segment of a certain type
of person uh and you know it won like
all the oscars that year and everything
like that which
you know a lot of people were pissed
about because that was the year that
pulp fiction was also nominated which
probably should have won
but so it's like this big beloved movie
and it's funny how it took like
20 years really for them to come around
to making it because i think the book
came out like in the [ __ ] 70s or
something
the backdrop is they got all this great
music that was i remember the soundtrack
being really good
and all these great moments in the life
of a boomer
all right and in place where all these
great moments in the lives of the
boomers was actually
done because some idiot happened
[Laughter]
so it didn't i didn't understand what
the message was yeah i mean
i guess boomer values are basically
basically
the product of idiots that's how i
which that kind of sounds legit
boomer values are idiotic or the
products of an idiot
camp guys that have never read the book
yeah the book is uh really not good but
it's crazy it's
crazy like crazy [ __ ] happens i was just
remembering you know
the boomers of the time their commentary
about how
great the movie was and they're in the
they're in the theaters reliving their
[ __ ] youth and their past and it's
all that the narrative is being [ __ ]
dictated to them
through the power of idiots and then
they walked away satisfied somewhere and
i go yeah boomers are [ __ ] dumb
[Laughter]
boomers are [ __ ] dumb if they made a
movie about everything that i believed
in and cherished and all the great mo
and it was all
because of some idiot i'd be insulted
but not a boomer
not a boomer boomer drank that up oh
yeah yeah yeah
hand me the margaritaville hawaiian
shirts and go down to [ __ ] boca and
[ __ ]
oh yeah yeah man it's really cool
you know that that's that's what you
deal with yeah yeah mango said bad books
can make great movies from time to time
yeah i think that was kind of um i think
that's kind of they did i don't think
they wanted to say that because like
winston groom's dead and i guess they
didn't really want to like uh you know
impugn the memory of a dead person but
um i mean one of the execs did straight
up say like it's not a very good book
but there was apparently something about
it that resonated because like i said
even before it was published i think
they were still
they were like knocking around the you
know the idea of making it into a movie
because it was like this one woman and
she read the book and she just like
she loved the character and thought it
would make a great movie and spent like
the next 20 years trying to get the
[ __ ] thing made
do you know what's another old boomer
movie that has reminded me a lot of this
was that movie we saw in the theater
that had
it was taking place here in florida had
that old loser down there in
[ __ ] miami hey the beach bum beach
beef is that what it's called beach ball
he's hanging out with snoop dogg yeah
and his wife is [ __ ] snoop dogg and
[ __ ] that was a harmony kareem
yeah that's might as well be force gump
that was that same [ __ ] thing just a
total worthless drop
although i liked the beach it was
actually just it was odd
it was honest about what it was well
yeah it was self-aware
it was just about this totally worthless
worthless drunk and no matter what he
does he somehow wins
yeah it's almost i mean there is that's
you know that's not coming out of
nowhere because there have been other
movies and
even stories like going back hundreds of
years like that yeah of just this kind
of like
[ __ ] that just like stumbles into
greatness yeah it just keeps failing
upwards but that is yeah that is like a
narrative trope that has been
like used before so i do think that
that's where they were getting you want
to see
if you were not happy with forrest gump
all right but want to see a film
about some worthless [ __ ] who
just fails upwards
see that one see beach bum and it's a
florida movie it's up there with [ __ ]
[ __ ] uh a pain and gain and uh
and another [ __ ] fight with my family
you know i mean it is entertaining
but at least it's not trying to hold
itself up as some kind of [ __ ] great
moralistic [ __ ] because i look at
forrest gump and i think it's a troll
it's troll and boomers i think yeah
that's possible i think it's like the
whole movie was a troll that's possible
yeah yeah fourth renown said life is not
like a box of chocolates a block of
chocolates has a diagram
telling you which one it is what one
each one is that's true and i always
thought that
and the thing about it is like all the
famous lines
from uh from forrest gump the movie
there were none of those were in the
book like life is like a box of
chocolates
like all of that was that was the
screenwriter who was i think his name
was eric roth or something like that
but yeah you can go down to [ __ ]
walgreens and get you a box of the
sucker
all year round they're selling boxes of
[ __ ] chocolates for some event or
another whitman's
whitman's stuff whitman's sampler and
you can tell how how many creams are in
there by the price
if the price is low that shit's creams
if the price is high then that's
because creams are [ __ ] creams are
[ __ ]
although they have gotten a little bit
better over the years
i had got one of those sampler ones and
that had some of those fruit creams they
were a lot better than they used to be
when i was a kid
they were [ __ ] terrible remember kid
they improved the flavors of them a
little bit because sometimes
not as good as a caramel sometimes
somebody would [ __ ] with you like if
someone because my grandma got it
and like switch the [ __ ] around to
like turn the tray around so you thought
and then you thought
oh this is a nice coconut or it's one
with nuts and then you're like ah
you [ __ ] they even made the
jellies a little better remember they
had some more like
jelly yeah they're a little better than
they used to be i mean i
just kind of want caramels or nuts or
coconut you get one
and otherwise get that one get the [ __ ]
out i don't want no [ __ ] fruit cream
in that chocolate [ __ ] yeah
that box is [ __ ] 20 something bucks
then you know it's mostly terrible
if you go in there and it's the six
dollar box that's creep
and i'm sure there are some people that
would be very very happy to get the free
creams because there are some weirdos in
the world that like like those but well
i gotta admit they're better than they
were
i don't like it they're a little chewier
yeah you know what i mean they're a
little chewier and the flavors are
better than they used to be back in the
70s they were horrible
well everything was kind of like cheaper
back then yeah it's like you know
yeah we just didn't know any better i
was gonna say going back production
yeah slasher fred said one of my
favorite steven spielberg films is duel
that is a great [ __ ] movie
yeah it was not for tv though it was
yeah actually he made
um he made quite a few papers he made
that that was like his most famous one
but he made another one
called i think it was called something
evil and it was like a kind of
haunted house c pagani witchcrafty type
of thing
and um i remember that being pretty
[ __ ] good i saw it a few years ago
because i was like what steven spielberg
fourth year
down mentions that that movie is kind of
like that the movies you're talking
about are kind of like
being there yeah though being there i
haven't seen a long time
i want to see it again i remember it
being a masterpiece
yeah i really liked being there and it
had secret societies involved where you
had like basically
globalist [ __ ] globalist masonic
order a [ __ ] super rich dudes that
were picking presidents and [ __ ]
and it had a lot of symbolism of you
know like
kind of like masonic orders and secret
societies
picking these presidents and chauncey
ends up they've ends up picking chauncey
but it's a weird stuff where he walks
across the water like a savior and [ __ ]
that was [ __ ] weird too yeah so
i don't see it again yeah i i feel like
it's time for a revisit i haven't
seen that since probably i think i
rewatched it in the 90s at some point
but i haven't seen it again since then
it was a trip because part of the
lessons were true that appearances
[ __ ] go very far in the world
because he was an idiot but because a
super rich guy was taking care of him he
had the mannerisms and the clothes of a
rich person
and he was being taken care of by you
know maids and servants and stuff
and he he could pass himself off as a
real rich [ __ ] wise man he was
[ __ ]
homeless he got kicked out of home he'd
walk up to an hour just
random black women and ask for food and
[ __ ] like that because
all the black all the black women he
knew fed him and when he when he was
being taken care of this [ __ ] it's a
trip man it is a trip movie
it is yeah yeah and he goes and they're
selling televisions and he's just
sitting there watching tv in the [ __ ]
store windows and trying to turn it
turn the channels with his fingers and
[ __ ] or
when did he try to turn the channels
with an imaginary uh
i can't remember that it's been like a
long time yeah i remember i remember it
being a good movie
camp guy said good road chase movie is
the hitcher with rutgerhauer we did a
review of that
uh not too long ago and then slasher
fred says if you guys ever see the movie
westworld we did a review on that one as
well a long time ago
uh the original westworld i think they
well they did the series
which i kind of wanted to watch because
it looked like it was good but i haven't
got around to camp guys saying and being
there he was like a guru
no they're fooling you he was not a guru
he was an idiot but because of the way
he spoke and the way people thought he
was a good people read into it
as if he was a guru and would actually
make decisions based on what he said
that would work out but it wasn't him it
was them
they were interpreting what he said kind
of like kind of like one of those holy
oracles
out of [ __ ] midsummer where she it's
just a
an inbred person who can't think and
because they're unclouded by
thought they can just scribble some [ __ ]
you could interpret it
yeah the wise man couldn't breathing the
chickens
just reading chicken and trails because
he would just go
business is like a plant planting seeds
and things grow
but he was a gardener that's the only
way he was
planting seeds yeah it sounded super
deep that was it was like some deepak
chopra
right d-pack show where you can just put
a bunch of random words together
and that's what deepak chopra does
there's a there's a program that
that yeah like generator that'll
generate a deepak chopra statement
and it'll sound just like and it's
indistinguishable because i
i spent a day like [ __ ] with that one
time because i just thought it was so
funny
and i just i could not distinguish it'd
be like a super wise computer program
and it's [ __ ] yeah
a cockroach is more intelligent than
that computer program but it sounds deep
as [ __ ]
that's you reading into it well that's
kind of like well
and oracle just pointed out like a fake
psychic doing a cold reading
that's that's essentially what that is
they're just trying to pick up
cues from [ __ ] that you say your body
language like what you look like you
know
stuff like that they're just trying to
pick up cues from that and then trying
to like
lead you down to like certain directions
and you're kind of doing most of the
work because
you're supplying a lot more information
to them than you think that you are
so that's kind of how that works out um
yeah so yeah so we talked about most of
them right we talked about
four of them the i think season one i
can't remember all the movies they did
on season one i remember they did dirty
dancing
and uh i can't remember what the other
ones were but it's like i really really
like this i think i like
the toys that made us like a little bit
better
yeah but the movies that made us is
really good too because like i said even
if it's a movie i don't really like all
that much
it's still like really interesting i'm
interested particularly movies that were
like really really
popular it kills me that even a movie
that
you know nowadays everybody's just like
oh jurassic park you know
back to the future it was like a
foregone conclusion but the fact that it
took so long
and went through so many and like there
was points where it wasn't gonna get
made and they had all this problem and
it's like you know we're
gonna cut the budget you can't do this
you can't do that and the fact that it
still came out as amazing as it came out
is kind of awesome which in a way like i
said that's kind of why
seeing stuff like that makes me a little
less harsh i guess on bad movies because
making a
making a movie is like hard under the
best circumstances
so when it's like and all the problems
that even the simplest
uh movie production goes through it's
like for it to
it almost seems like for it to end up
good is like a miracle
you know what i mean it just seems like
too many fingers in the pocket yeah
because it just seems like there's so
so many ways for it to go wrong um
and so when everything just comes
together and even as much as like
chaotic
as it was because i think that they had
um what's his name on there from
seinfeld that was talking about a pretty
woman because he was a pretty woman that
was like his first
film role and um he was saying the set
when they were filming pretty woman it
was gary marshall was the director
and he's like we had no [ __ ] idea
what kind of movie we're making because
gary marshall would just be like okay
let's do a serious take now let's do the
same scene but do it funny
and now let's do so he's like we had no
idea like what this movie was going to
end up like and we just thought it was
going to be a piece of [ __ ] because
we were just doing like three or four
different tones
you know of each scene and it's like we
didn't know how it was gonna all cut
together and they're like and the fact
that they cut it together and it ended
up being this massive hit was like they
were like it was amazing we didn't even
remember
making that movie because because
because everything was just a big [ __ ]
show
but um yeah so it's just goes to show
that even when
it's all like chaotic and [ __ ] up and
everything like that every now and then
uh something comes out good like i said
i can't say i remember liking pretty
woman when it came out i'm not bro big
in rom-coms
um i've seen some good ones but i
remember that one being good but i
haven't seen that one probably since the
90s
maybe i just saw it on cable yeah i
think i saw it on cape i don't think i
saw
i didn't give a [ __ ] yeah i don't think
i saw it in the theater or anything like
that so i don't really remember that
much about it
uh the toys that made this is a better
series
it is well because i'm kind of
interested in like the manufacturing and
like you know them coming up with like
the story behind all the toys and
everything with movies you know that
there's
personalities and you know that there's
[ __ ] stories involved with making a
story
okay but how would you you know how
you would never really think there was a
story say behind making he-man toys yeah
but it's and it's a fascinating [ __ ]
hilarious that the [ __ ] arguments and
the fights over these goddamn he-man
what started them even making a he-man
board rooms full of grown people arguing
over a green title and then all the lies
you have to tell
to get he-man done and [ __ ] tell you
like oh well
it's the comic books coming out the
movie because and they're
wait yeah totally yeah yeah yeah
comic book hurry somebody made somebody
make a comic book yeah yeah
they lied their way and [ __ ] who
would have thought
that he-man which the new he-man just
came out and people are
critiquing that he-man came into
existence because they had a shitty
solid plastic [ __ ] tiger
that they had to sell that's what
started it
toy company had this molded tiger it's
about this big
and it didn't sell there and they just
walked in and goes we got to [ __ ]
sell that [ __ ]
so they have like millions of these and
they just went like
paint that [ __ ] green put yellow
stripes on it
another guy goes put a saddle on it and
make a man ride it
and that's how it started and you're
going but dude the scale is off you know
look look at look at how big that
[ __ ] man is next to that [ __ ]
thing
where the tiger was yeah look how big
that tiger is next to that man that's
[ __ ] that
that's the size of a horse and dude said
put a saddle on that thing put that man
on there and that's how [ __ ] he-man
was born and
it was they had to like build a story
yeah and these are [ __ ]
you know 20-something-year-old 30 year
old man man
children that totally understand the
thinking of [ __ ] little boys going
we're going to make him [ __ ] badass
roid that [ __ ]
you're making this action figure bigger
and bigger like super steroid and
they're going
the boys are going to love that i have
the power
because your mom's [ __ ] with you you
know [ __ ] with you you can't make any
decisions for yourself so
the little boys are going to say i have
the power that's where power of gray
skull came from
what kind of power is it it's the power
of skulls man
yeah they're writing the [ __ ] down
brainstorming drinking thinking like
they're trying to think like
nine-year-old boys
well and it worked and it was in the
he-man situation it definitely worked
yeah i mean you don't really hear about
all the what times it is the stories
behind he-man
are [ __ ] hilarious all of those shows
all of them
there was a [ __ ] they did one about
he-man they did one about gi joes they
did a barbie one
they did um [ __ ] man they did uh what
was that
what was that other thing did they do
they didn't do smurfs that's not really
a toy
that was um [ __ ] now i can't remember
all the ones they did
uh barbie they did [ __ ] transformers
transformers
gi joe did they do uh was there a
strawberry shortcake one
uh i don't know i don't know my little
pony my little pony is my little pony
one you see
then they and you and here's another
thing is that you
the behind the scenes toy making these
toy making guys
[ __ ] ruthless back in the day and
they were just doing this [ __ ] just on
the fly
and coming up with his stuff on the fly
and trying to make money
but they understood psychology real well
they were trying to when they were
building up he-man they had to build
he-man up into the ultimate [ __ ]
masculinity
from the point of view of a [ __ ]
eight-year-old boy okay that's as macho
as you could get
and then they had a girl in another
department says well we're going to make
a female version of sheba and they're
like no
no no and as soon as she girls are angry
as soon as shiba came out then all the
[ __ ] little boy street cred [ __ ]
vanished on he-man sales [ __ ]
plummeted those he had
because he's like ooh no now my sister
once yeah
because [ __ ] rule number one children
are sexist
little children are sexist that's right
they're just born that way
i play i like to do i mean my my brother
was four years younger so he had like
some pretty kick-ass toys i liked his
uh we we had we both had legos um
and we both really liked star wars star
wars toys as well some
some of those toy lines were kind of
neutral gems yeah
not really neutral gender they were just
i mean yeah i feel like i feel like
legos were pretty neat legos were kind
of neutral anybody could run
i mean you could build whatever you
wanted with erector sets and the stuff
but those were kind of old
school erector sets when i was a kid
they had some of them were kind of cool
but they just couldn't compete with
legos
legos were better yeah they were yeah
they had i was i remember i had a kick
ass like lego space shuttle
set yeah star wars mostly appealed to
little boys but some little girls liked
it because you had princess leia and
[ __ ]
i you know what i liked i think my
favorite um
star wars star wars sour barber my
favorite
star wars toys i liked i really loved
the dagobah playset i was really into
that
and i really really liked um the taunton
and the little han with this little blue
park on
the taunton's like tummy open so you
could like put han in there and keep him
warm
or am i remembering that wrong he went
through the top so he could sit in there
i don't know i know he could sit in
there but i didn't
i didn't remember if the belly open
maybe maybe i was just maybe i was just
imagining
maybe i wished that it's belly maybe
they had a special version but
where all his little guts would come out
you also can get people to ride on a
dewback
yeah i had that i had the [ __ ] i had
most of those toys
except i didn't have the big walkers
yeah i think did my brother have one of
those by the time that was ready
to come out i was already old enough to
not really be into the into the toys
that much
yeah yeah they were something that just
kind of sat around i was moving on to
other stuff so they did do
they actually they did do a toys that
made us about star wars toys i think
they did yeah
they did there was yeah there's a bunch
of those but yeah netflix really killing
it with these uh
something that made us shows but like
boys are better than the movies yeah but
the movies are good too and like i said
i'm kind of like interested
i think that since i know more about
movies like some of the stories behind
the movies i already kind of knew some
of the stuff
but the toy ones you don't like know as
much because like you said you don't
really think about
all the stuff that goes into like that
yeah like the idea the idea that barbie
dolls were based on a german hooker doll
yeah that's all but yep and it was
little dolls that guys gave the german
call girls yep which i guess didn't
really have the dating scene i guess in
germany
after the war you're a doll for you guys
kind of paid for their girlfriends and
it was kind of like a girlfriend
relationship she might have a couple
boyfriends
but if you know your favorite girlfriend
you gave her this little [ __ ] doll it
was
based on a german a german comic book
character that was in the newspapers and
it was
about a little german call girls i guess
all you german hotties after
after the war there wasn't much work you
know so all you german hotties they were
girlfriends for hire kind of like a
gigolo
yeah what's the female equivalent of a
gigolo call girl
yeah or escort a girl yellow or
a girl glove you know
the difference is the price
[Laughter]
yeah yeah that's another thing too
that's another thing about pretty woman
is that
i know it's a rom-com and they're like
unrealistic but it's like i don't think
i've ever seen like a hollywood
hooker that looked anything like julia
roberts or laura sanchez she looked like
that she would not be walking around
she might be working up in vegas or
something like that yeah hanging out
in in uh in casinos and shaking dice for
people and [ __ ] like that and [ __ ]
you know
if you're a if you if you won big that
night she's gonna go up the hotel room
with you
money's not discussed but you know that
shit's not gonna be free
okay that's true yeah all right
you ready to wrap it up uh yeah we shut
it down okay
so uh yeah so movies that made us season
two
four episodes about four hours of
entertainment uh just dropped on netflix
i don't know it might have been a few
days ago i haven't checked netflix in a
couple of days but i just saw it last
night so
go check it out it's there if you
haven't seen it and it's super fun
uh so i guess we're gonna watch whatever
we watch tonight and we'll talk about
that again tomorrow at the same time 3
p.m
eastern standard so have a good rest of
your monday
and we will see you guys again tomorrow
bye